[Music]
Joanna Gaines hospitalized before the
holidays I have realized that if you
hold change well and you hold it in
health we're all just better for it on
Wednesday the Magnolia Network star
shared this pic of herself lying in a
hospital bed in good spirits holding up
a peace sign as she wears Shades and a
hospital gown as for why well Joanna
explains in the caption that she
suffered from a long-term back injury
since she was a cheerleader in high
school sharing she had her first
microdiscectomy in 2001 a surgical
operation that helps relieve pain for
herniated disc in the spine and Joanna
reveals she had the same procedure on
another disc two weeks ago it's real
life for us but despite Joanna's Health
setback she's looking on the bright side
the interior designer also shared this
sweet snapshot hugging one of her kids
next to the Christmas tree Joanna says
quote I've always joked that my back
likes to act up at the most inconvenient
times and I was a bit stressed because
of the timing of it all with the holiday
season but I'm truly grateful for the
forced rest during the busiest time of
the year it has been a gift to Simply
stay put stare at the Wonder All Around
and just be still
I feel like life is just going really
fast these days there's so much on our
plate and it's it's great stuff but with
that comes a lot of the pressures and
um you know the deadlines when I get
home I've got to get mentally grounded
so that I don't feel overwhelmed or lose
my mind and for me that's the simple
things while Joanna enjoys some down
time during the holidays she and her
hubby chip will have lots to look
forward to in 2023 including their 20th
wedding anniversary and that means a lot
it does and it and it feels good when ET
caught up with the couple chip shared
his advice for a long lasting marriage I
mean at the end people ask us for
marriage advice it's just be like I mean
there's no there's no secret ingredient
it's just be good to each other man if
you're being ugly to each other it's
hard to operate a marriage in that
environment when you're good to one
another and same with relationships
outside of marriage like friendships
it's like when you're a good friend when
you're the kind of friend that you'd
want to have it's amazing how your
friendships last the test of time you
know and I think in this modern time so
many people make so many simple mistakes
it's just be good to be good be good to
one another
[Music]